hey anything out the purse girl huh she
knew it sure yeah don't you get on that
it's not really my type
what are you gay hmm I don't think so no
what is your type
mom's primarily yep soccer moms single
moms NASCAR moms any type of mom really
that's disgusting
stay away from my mom too late oh man I
would be all over that if I wasn't
dating Pam we're not dating we're
engaged engaged yeah
Pam and I are good buddies I'm sort of
Pam's go-to guy for her problems
you know with stuff like work or her
fiance Roy or no those are pretty much
her only two problems she'd be perfect
for you mm-hmm
she'd been talking to Michael a lot so
what your assistant regional manager
stint to the regional manager you know
what do like he's your work boss
okay he's not your relationship bug
that's true you've so much more to talk
to this girl about you're both salesmen
I mean that's something right there true
plus I could talk to her about the
origins of my last name it's all gold
guys are usually my best customers they
buy the high-end stuff like the beads
and the sequins and stuff for gifts you
know they don't know what they're
looking at so I make suggestions all
right here's the thing okay just keep
talking to her if you hit a stall you
have a perfect ball bag what's that you
buy a purse I don't want to parse purses
are for girls Dwight that's not
necessarily true okay do you read GQ no
okay
I do they're like mini briefcases all
right lots of guys have like those yes
listen you're spending way too much time
talking okay I'm just gonna use the
bathroom and no you don't need the
bathroom you've got it go is going to be
good
hi my name is Dwight Schrute and I would
like to buy a purse from you good lord
look at these purses this is something
special
oh my god is this Salvatore genie us oh
definitely definitely step in and out of
it like that yes I want to stress tested
you know in case anything happened oh
that was really
it's necessary to really give it a good
workout this is the Oh this is the
prettiest one of our I'm gonna be the
prettiest girl in the bar oh how much oh
it's sad it's sad
you